so we're back in Roseanne's kitchen
table what are we doing here find out
right here there's an annotation go
right there so Jimmy was on my show with
Ben mankiewicz a couple weeks ago and we
talked a little bit about Ferguson and
the protest and you were going on some
conspiracy theories and the comment
section went bananas now YouTube
comments they tend to go bananas but
people have the people really hated what
you were saying and half the people you
were there knew Jesus you were red
pilling yes that's what they said which
i guess is take off of what Rios choice
in the matrix red pilling meaning you
were going down the rabbit hole you want
to know the truth kind of thing so I'm
I'm not as deep in the conspiracy
theories but I think we all have some
conspiracy theories that we buy I kind
of buy something went down with JFK
something like that but can you give me
a link can you think I me a little
something there's a little kind of I'd
see that movie many times and yeah but
when you go down that road what's the
thought process when you're going down
the conspiracy theories oh so so what I
know you like info you likes yes and
when we talk about news all the time you
like actual numbers that you can so what
I was saying well see what I think the
mistake people were making on that first
clip put through we talked about I was
saying that I thought my theory was that
the cop set some of those fires right in
Ferguson I wasn't saying that I can
prove it I'm saying that's my theory
right I'm not saying I'm willing to be
just you know I'm not so that was just a
theory right I wasn't saying that is
what happens like you're not saying you
have evidence for now I'm just going
down I'm saying that my gut feeling
would be that the cops have proven
themselves to be criminals at every step
along the way why wouldn't they also try
to discredit the protesters in this way
they've released it at night it's
obviously they wanted to have some kind
of a riot they overreact left and right
there they lie left and right the
prosecutor was whitewashing this from
day one he doesn't care that people can
see right through him that he's
transparently corrupt so why wouldn't
they do that that was my question really
why wouldn't they do it so is this one
of those things where people just won't
believe it until there is the smoking
gun or in this case so until there's
video of a cop actually planting a bomb
in a blow didn't even need to be a
ha I mean like I said before you know
cops often have criminals do their dirty
work for them right so I mean I used to
watch beretta yeah and so my my my my
bigger point was that half of those
people who are going crazy on the
YouTube comments there you know white
people who are naive right and or like
when I talk about Michael Schur and ana
kasparian we talk about cops they don't
think like criminals I saw Chris Hayes I
grew up around criminals right my dad
was a cop my grandpa was a cop my oldest
brother was a cop three of my best
friends were cops and I'd have another
you half of my neighborhood were all
criminals I'm not kidding yeah so they
don't understand that cops are also
criminals and then they don't think like
that Chris Hayes from MSNBC brought on
the head of the police union in st.
Louis who was freaking out that some st.
Louis Rams did this and so and he
couldn't nail them because every time he
was dumbfounded that this criminal cop
was gonna act like a criminal he thought
he would act like a reasonable person
and it's like because chris haynes lives
in a little bubble and he doesn't
realize those guys are criminals and he
doesn't understand i think like a
criminal i luckily am a criminal so I
think like a criminal right so to me
with all the conspiracy theory stuff
it's like I can entertain it to a degree
like when we had that conversation
that's basically what i was saying i can
entertain this stuff and you showed me
you later sent me a video that made it
look like top maybe did us a little
something i can go there to a degree but
then there's another piece of me and i
think this is just human psychology that
it's like unless i have that proof my
brain like you can only spend so much
time going down that road so i guess
that sort of strengthens the anti
conspiracy theory well the thing that
people what's funny to me is that that
will have people discredit the 911
people who don't don't buy the
government story I don't think anybody
buys the government story right right do
we but um the thing is that stuff that
we know about George Bush and Dick
Cheney is way worse than what the 911
truthers are saying in the first place
so why would that be crazy the stuff we
know they started a warrant illegally we
know they ordered war crimes to cover it
up and now the torture report comes out
and says there's a wave more brutal than
we ever knew so the stuff that we know
about
is worse than if they would have allowed
911 happened in the first place and you
know what people the whole point of this
is for us to relax and have coffee and
talk in a more decent way and as you can
see Jimmy who smokes a tremendous amount
of pot I haven't smoked fighting he
hasn't smoked pot that's why he's all
fired up anyway what do you think is
this guy completely bonkers when it
comes to conspiracy theories do you
follow along or do you just let them be
where they are let us know in the
comments right down below